nothing to keep you going but once you
are going it just goes
it just goes no i'm getting shivers
yeah i'm getting shivers
[Music]
guys the merch is popping you know big
man merch is popping i don't know if you
can see in the camera this one's this
one's live it's on the bridge you've got
the
you know what i hate you got loads of
vibrant
[ __ ] you love vibrancy
it works with your skin and i know what
works with my skin so that's why i get
the gunmetal grays
stop saying gunmetal grey that's why i
get the government of grace
because i know what works for me but
then when i see yours i'm like well
obviously i should have got that
because that looks you need to test it
you need testing i have to test the
waters but i haven't got energy for it
um but i will i will that looks that
looks bad after orange one look buff
um that bluetooth user in the other day
look bath obviously it's not much but it
might have to be it might have to be
why not me um quick monster slurp
i was gonna say do your [ __ ] slurp
for these asmr for these hoes
that's [ __ ] tasty one of these days
bruv
i'm going to have you do a monster slap
and the the gang's going to go wild
the family the day you drink a monster
the fam are going to go mad
um so yeah g mission 1k
mission 1k is on and officially [ __ ]
pop in
it really is on and popping it really
fast so guys thank you
um just keep moving obviously we're
still in early numbers so let's keep uh
bumping it up mission 1k if you're new
to the
the phrase um once we hit 1 thousand
pounds on patreon
fujado and i will be dropping two
episodes a week and they're going to be
long as [ __ ]
they're probably like two hours long
okay so um
yeah man help us out links in the
description
if you follow us on instagram links are
in the bio links are [ __ ] everywhere
everywhere don't complain yeah you can't
not find the patreon
um and then obviously patreon's full of
bonus episodes and perks so
yeah do your thing same old same old
um audio listen subscribe
youtube watches subscribe and let's get
into it
any azure business you've got any urgent
business i never have really urgent
business i just always have [ __ ] to talk
about really
i'm more of a i'm more of a tangent guy
you are you look good
i love a tangent all right well in that
case before
you get into tangents um
[Music]
i've got a fan request okay yes so fan
requests i love that always urgent biz
um so fan request
is lovely lady called rel relly real
anyway she wants to know what we think
if we've got any stories or and uh
experiences of girls shooting their shot
if i've got any experience of girls
shooting the shop i feel like
more what do you think about gushing i
think it's a great thing for girl
shooting this shot i think it's the best
thing
because a lot of
women think shooting their shot is just
looking at a guy
in the shops i know they do that's all
that's what that's what they think
shooting their shot is because
to me that's not shooting your shot to
me it's not shooting in your shop
and to other women they're not shooting
their shot when they're staring at me
you know what i mean yeah because i've
had yes obviously everyone knows by now
when i talk to girls
but i've had girls stare me the [ __ ]
down yeah and i'm like well this is this
is a done deal
and then i go and shoot my shot and
they're just like ill
they're just like yuck no and it's just
like i'm not crazy big man you stared at
me for five minutes
we didn't blink for time clearly you
want something you once saw him and now
you're paying me off so yeah
so from there alone now i can't even
take that a shooting shot
is that i contact him because i've been
hurt before so i can't say that eye
contacting is a shooting shot
i've been heard before but yeah sorry
carry on um so yeah i don't think um
eye contact is shooting the shot but
girls that are
shooting the shot via eye contact think
it's shooting their shots yes and it's
the most frustrating thing it is
and not necessarily because i
they obviously have the balls or
whatever to go up to a guy because
and they would regardless but they their
fear of rejection is
is wild to me like if you're a buff i
think you're swinging like this before
on here if you're a buff you're not
gonna get rejected
like if you're in a shrubs ninety
percent of the mandem will [ __ ] you 100
and the thing is as well you're only as
i was talking about
someone as well you know you're lame as
well so it's not even the thing is it's
not even about if it's not even about if
you're buff or not
because you know you're lame you know
your criteria you know what [ __ ] with
you and who doesn't [ __ ] yeah exactly so
if you're a six
you're not going to be shooting to the
don that's a 10. you're just not going
you're not going to and if you are and
vice versa
as well big bad if you are fair play do
your thing and get paid that's your
business see what happens and if you
don't get pride
round of applause i'm holding the
council i didn't want to do a round of
applause if you shoot your shot you're a
six and you grab a ten
round of applause guys and girls thank
you well done i'm not gonna risk my life
like that yeah
i stay in my legs i'm not willing to
risk it all like that
i've never shot my shot out of ten i
have but not
face to face like always like dm stuff
like when they post sign flames i was
like oh
yeah you see it where they're really
easy that's that's an easy low risk
high reward you know i mean low risk or
some hazarding
low risk high reward those zones are
high low is hyrule
face to face never never i have to be
confident i have to be walking in like
i'm [ __ ] i don't know superman
i'd have to be on heroin i'd have to be
on smack
in order for me to have the balls to do
that but yeah anyway yeah obviously if
you if you play by the rules and you
stay in your lane
and you're a girl shooting your shot is
like shooting fish in a barrel
you're guaranteed cuz guaranteed if
you're a six and you're shooting your
shot at another six guaranteed
you're [ __ ] tonight guaranteed and if
you're not interested in [ __ ] tonight
your security's number your screen is
graham
you're screwing the snapchat anything
easy easy
and it's infuriating like i was actually
gonna have i had a rant i haven't had a
rant in ages
i had a rant about that in my phone but
i haven't brought out before
but i've probably said it before
it infuriates me how easy for women it
is to get oh
god it is so annoying just and it's not
even
because it's so ingrained in their dna
now yeah just i spoke to you just
about how they flagrantly talk about it
in just how the way they describe a
scenario to them from their perspective
is completely different to how i could
ever perceive it
yeah so like a girl saying oh man's
like if if a girl looks uh uh instagram
and she's seen one don has followed her
like three pictures and as preeta story
yeah
she's contemplating whether or not she's
going to [ __ ] him or not
do you know what i mean yeah she's
contemplating when she's gonna fight
when she's gonna [ __ ] him should i add
him to the list or not yeah and has he
got a girlfriend
and then he's got if they do a bit of
research and if he's buffed they're like
okay cool and then even if they've got a
girlfriend they still
decide whether they're going to [ __ ] him
because they don't really care yeah
exactly girls don't really
need to cycle they're so 99 certain that
just the fact that he's
liked a couple pictures that she knows
if she slides in
she's gonna get the dick yeah regardless
if he's married girlfriend kids whatever
just from that she decides she's in
control now she makes all the rules
don't want to [ __ ] this guy or not if a
girl likes three of my pictures
it's like a blueprint that comes out of
my head and you know um
what was it from uh hangover you know
when he's doing the always that meme
that comes up
the hangover meme where my man's playing
blackjack and he learned how to count
cards and then yeah yeah
the numbers are good yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's me
the algorithm is like three picks
sometimes
yeah yeah yeah if you've seen man's
story and she hasn't reacted i'm just
like
okay yeah and then fram it's a whole
ordeal
and they're different for us even though
she's made the first move it's then up
to me
to decide how i'm gonna shoot my shot
now in the hope
that even though she's the one that made
the first move in the hope that maybe
one day we might have sex it's not even
my sex she if she responds
she might not even respond she should
air it she might just [ __ ] air might
not respond
and it's just completely it's so
frustrating so when women are there like
uh
i don't i'm too scared to shoot my
shoulders fear of rejection fear of
rejection for women is not a thing it's
not a thing as long as you stay in your
lane as long as you stay in your lane if
you don't
if you shoot your shot like like you
said if you shoot your shot if you're a
six and you or if you think you're a six
and shoot your shot
for a ten then obviously you're only
doing yourself harm
like of course more time guys do it just
to see whether they can get or not if
they
if they don't get it it doesn't really
matter if they get crazy if they get it
then it's
a bonus guys with no fear
of rejection are crazy people but
sometimes sometimes but they just don't
see the word no they don't
they don't see it and they don't hear it
it doesn't make sense it's scary
for a woman that's scary tell a man no
and he just
just doesn't hear it and just carries on
especially if it's the same chick and
they get repetit
repetitively yeah if they're continuing
continuously
i would say they're continuously trying
to move to the same chick she said no no
no no no
no no no no no no no oh my days oh my
days yeah it's not it's not the lick
it's not the lick at all but no she i
think girls should always shoot their
shirt they should always have the
confidence to shoot their shot
they should it's i feel like
it's such a social construct to leave it
to the guys
per se you know
i know girls do do it too but it's more
time the guys that do it
than the girls and it's just so it's
such a such a social construct and the
thing is for
when a girl does it as long as she
doesn't do it like a guy
yeah it's a turn on for a guy if she
moves to man and emasculates him
then let me pattern this thing for you
no you have to do a tight tie
tie tight
then you're not you won't secure me i
can promise you that you could be buff
as you like
if you emasculate me you want to secure
me that night um but if you
if you move to me with finesse and
you're just yeah
like i can you're making it obvious that
you're shooting your shot yeah yeah
trust me i'm secured yeah if you're buff
i'm secure i'm secured
no one else is getting this but you
patting me it's calm like it's so easy
like it's a turn on for a guy
it's a [ __ ] turn on for a guy man
and just chasing girls is not sexy for a
guy it's not it's just not fun for us
it depends on the longevity of the chase
obviously of course it depends obviously
when you have a little back and forth
with the same girl and it's just like
it's like a hard to getting
yes that's sexy but if in first
instances
in first instances and you know i'm
looking for kind of
some form of immediate gratification
like i'm seeing i'm seeing you in person
so obviously
i'm not even talking about social media
here yeah the chase is finding social
media to a degree
because there's no rush yeah yeah yeah
there's no rush here yeah yeah yeah so
yeah all this like like for likes follow
follow back
[ __ ] um reacting to stories
shooting over gifts and stuff like that
all of that is fun all of that's fun
um for a time as well obviously that's
got it's time to but that's for a
different day
um um but
in person in person like
for a guy to know that he has to like
really step
up and do something here if he wants to
secure anything
he actually has to put himself on a
plate it's just stressful for a guy to
do that all the time
stressful got to do that all the time
and then there's no like
you need when you do that in person you
need immediate gratification yeah like
she can't be like
i don't know she can't just like laugh
and walk off yeah like on instagram and
stuff like that if you if you send
someone
a little something and they send you
like a laughing face and then move on
that's done that's fine yeah that's all
you needed because you know you've
planted your seed and you can wait as
long as it takes
yeah wait for the next time but when i'm
in person cousin i'm running up to you
you need to give me something running up
you need to give me something now yeah
like you need to let me know that i've
been successful in my attempts yeah
none of this giggle and walker waiting
in the hope that i might see you again
no no no no no that's dead so stuff like
that it stresses me out so that's i
don't like shooting my shot anyway so if
a girl if you know me if you're a girl
shoot your shot because i won't i've
said it before i'm tired of saying it
shoot your shot cause i won't so yeah
anyway that's funny
yeah it's a real aim of fire
shoot that rail you will you you won't
lose
um i wanted to big up i don't want to
get her name wrong so i'm going to
actually find it
you know what i'm going to say anyway um
the cat
catching oh yeah yeah so
deep pocket cat
[Music]
deep pocket cat that's hilarious so
obviously at the beginning of almost
every episode we talk about uh mission
1k on the patreon and whatnot
and one lovely lady lovely lovely lady
i'm trying to find her name
sorry guys i just followed her actually
on our personal none on our
shits and giggs account um so her name
is
cat shanu she's amazing she's amazing so
obviously
we we hit uh we hit a milestone
yesterday
on our patreon and obviously i
i messaged i messaged jimmy and we were
like oh gas gang and we got
another email notification and i thought
that was an email confirmation
confirming the milestone we had hit
we were both wrong so this lovely lady
cat shannon
i hope i'm saying your name right by the
way just
deep pocket deep [ __ ] cat she reached
in
and you know i said [ __ ] it you man have
that she said hold that she said hold
that hold that so all you men that are
doing a three pound ten pound
yes i'm saying you man are riders yo you
are riders pocket cat deep pocket cat
she said
she she she gave us the fourth tier i'm
not going to say the figures
if you want to know what the figures are
go on our patreon and see what the
fourth tier is she gave us the fourth
tier
yeah she contributed to the cause in a
big way in a big way
nfl booster whatever you're going to do
so sponsoring we see you
sponsoring sponsoring we [ __ ] see you
so that was that's your little shout out
for the day
yeah talk we will [ __ ] talk because
you're amazing thank you so much for
that
i got deep [ __ ] today oh hit me bro i
love deep [ __ ] yeah bro
let me get a good slap i love deep [ __ ]
see i got deep [ __ ] today so i was
listening
so this is this is me in my um
my little fantasy world that i love to
live in you know well i'm a dreamer
obviously you know i'm a dreamer yeah
yeah yeah
yeah i'm a dreamer [ __ ] it and i'm
obviously
i've said it a hundred times like i'm an
advocate for people chasing their dreams
and doing their [ __ ] and
just just just just [ __ ] after you're
nine to five if you can
yes like going for whatever it is you
want to do yes
just going for it yes and i listened to
a pod the other day
that was like wow the don that was on
there
so this was it was interesting this was
recommended to me because this was
basically it was on
it's an old episode of logan paul's
podcast okay
impulsive i don't listen to it i'm not
really necessarily a big fan of lookable
i have no reason to listen to logan
paul's podcast okay no offense to him
but it was a good episode
okay um and the guy he had on there was
one don called charlie this is time ago
i'm assuming
or i listened to it yesterday but it's a
oh old thing from like last year
okay um and not yesterday a couple days
ago
and um he basically the guy
on the charlie rocket is just the
epitome of someone chasing their dreams
okay
to the point where because it's all well
and good basically
long story short it's all well and good
to chase your dreams
when you're broke and [ __ ] because
it's only up from here yeah it's another
thing entirely
to when you've made it yeah in a
different sector sector completely
but it's not your dream and you want to
[ __ ] it all off to chase your dreams
yeah
that's another level entirely yeah yeah
that's another level entirely to me
so um basically the story of this guy
charlie rocket is basically
he's one don so i'll give you his whole
story we've got nowhere to be
i'll give you the whole deep so um
the whole d the whole deep oh
didn't actually say sorry that's going
on a t-shirt i'm going to give you next
i didn't come up with it i'll give you
the whole day
um right so my man basically started off
as like a kid
and he was fat okay and his dream he's
always said his dream
is to be an athlete oh his dreams to be
an athlete
and he wasn't necessarily sure what kind
of athlete he wanted to be
but he was so certain he was going to be
an athlete so he would just go around
tennessee i'm going to be an athlete i'm
going to be athlete
um but he hasn't never necessarily made
any moves to it
whereas most people if they're like i'm
going to be an athlete i need to start
playing basketball or i need to start
running i need to do something like he
was just so
very much like i don't know how it's
going to happen i don't know when it's
going to happen but
i'm going to be an athlete but he was
fat [ __ ] fat
and he but he hated that part about him
because obviously he's not an idiot he
knows
i can't just be fat and just be an asset
but anyway so
he wasn't getting any [ __ ] he wasn't
getting no love he wasn't getting
nothing so he said basically i need to
change
who i am entirely because i'm fat so i
can't be like one of the jocks at school
i have no talents i'm not musical uh he
said he grew up in
atlanta so there's like obviously a big
hip-hop scene in there he said i can't
rap i can't do [ __ ]
like i'm just a white girl like a white
guy okay so he said in order for me
to make if if i'm ever gonna get [ __ ]
basically
i need to just redesign myself yeah so
he decided [ __ ] it i'm gonna
create an alter ego and i'll start
calling myself c ceo charlie
okay ceo charlie and that's how i'm
gonna be okay so
he started off i see each charlie and he
used to come in in a suit and briefcase
to school
okay and he just started like working
with people who were into music
okay and trying to help them out so he
started off as like a cameraman he said
i don't want to be a cameraman so he
he started working with uh like groups
and stuff he said i'm gonna be a
cameraman
so um he was a cameraman for
soulja boy okay he was a cameraman for
soldier boy
and basically soldier sacked him because
he was too not too mouthy but basically
he was
um that's hilarious sorry to pause the
story i promise i'll come back
there's a donny pissing exactly where i
pissed the other day
and now i can see so basically not so
sure so cut off from the story
i got here when foo head was at work the
other day and i've never been so
desperate for a piss in my life and the
park car park opposite who has apartment
is so
open so open but i needed to piss so bad
i couldn't hold it so i had to piss in
the car park and i was certain only one
girl saw me who was just walking around
and that was embarrassing enough
but i can see my man clear as day and
he's pissing exactly where i pissed
and i know this entire block saw me now
yeah now i know everyone saw me
oh never mind never mind oh [ __ ]
um anyway so yeah ceo charlie he was a
cameraman for a soldier boy he got
sacked um and he was moving on and he
said basically i don't want to be a
cameraman anymore i want to be a manager
okay so he's 19 you're living with his
mom i said um he got
he's mad because he's moved into his
mom's basement like bear time so he was
living in his mom's basement
camera man for soldier boy managed to
move out soldier boy sacked him
moved back in they said i want to be a
manager manage this little girl group
um for a while moved back out they took
off
and they sacked him because in their
mind they're like
they will get offers from better
managers he's like i don't need a 19
year old manager
with this better offers out there sucked
so move back in
jesus then he discovered
uh who was it who was it
travis park no
there's a drum trap as well because
travis bark is a drummer there's only
travis parker travis scott i don't even
know there's another travis it's old
singer
um oh i'm gonna have that many travis's
there's a
i think it's travis
is it obviously he's a guy
uh it's what is it's like a group
a group thing or it's well it's a name
porter travis porter that name does ring
a bell
um i don't know who that is though it's
they're made uh make it rain
make it rain make it make it yeah old
team
okay okay okay hey ladies yeah uh
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yep
um so discover travis porter okay so
transport is actually a group apparently
i thought it was one done so it's a
group
yeah so anyway discover travis porter
took off um moved back out to be the mum
so
he's managing travis porter he's
securing deals here deals their deals
there
he's making millions um they are he is
all of them together so he's managing
them so he's making money they're making
money
okay he's got him signed um and
everything's going well yeah
these times his dreams always to be an
athlete oh yeah he's managing he's
making money now
about that yeah he's he's ceo charlie's
big don
yeah and then he's um
then he discovered two chains
and so he discovered two chains no he
didn't discover two chains
but he wasn't called two chains at the
time t boy he was called t-boy yeah
so um he met t-boy
yeah so he didn't discover i think he
was his fir he might have been his first
manager though
t boy's first manager okay and then um
so
botevo had a couple songs up he had no
manager no label one or nothing okay
and then um change um just work with
titty boy
changed over to two chains managing two
chains and now he's
topped on now so now he's set he's got
otherwise he's set yeah everything
managing two chains
done um he said he was bringing in about
15 million a year
he was chilling and then one day he was
just like i think he was like
305 pounds he was fat
and then he just decided you know what
i'm tired of this i
i'm not tired of this i'm living my life
but this isn't my dream yeah
this isn't my dream this is obviously
sick but this is not my dream
and man said the best quote i've ever
heard so he told um
two changes like brother i'm sorry but i
quit two times what the [ __ ] are you
talking about yeah
and he's like i quit i like i want to be
an athlete
and he's like big man look no offense
look at him yeah yeah
i want to be a nike athlete i want to be
a nike athlete like that's what i want
to do yeah that's my dream it's
always been my dream yeah and how is he
at this point do you know
he is 20 something early like 20
time yeah maybe 20 no
mid to late 20s okay so he's like this
is what i'm gonna do
yeah and then two changes like obviously
shut the [ __ ] up anything like that and
man said
like why would you do that like why
would you give up everything
to be something that you're never gonna
be and just chase a stupid dream
a man said bro i don't know if you've
noticed
but this is not my practice life this is
the only one i have
when i heard that i was just like
mad and when do chains heard it he was
like duty
do you think then okay fair play this is
not my practice life
this is the only one that right there
is the most mesmerizing thing that i've
ever heard
yeah considering i'm the guy that always
says [ __ ] like that anyway
yeah yeah just that structure of words i
was like big man i don't think enough
people realize that yeah
this is not our practice life this is
not a warm-up
this is the actual one i was thinking
about that the other day this is like
obviously everyone
knows you only live once yeah everyone
knows that but i don't know when no one
digests yeah no one digests
not enough people digest it hardly
anyone digests it and it's like
this this is it today this day
is the only this day we're gonna get
yeah tomorrow is the only tomorrow we're
gonna get yesterday
it's gone it's gone you're never getting
that back all the cool [ __ ] i did
yesterday is done
it's never gonna happen again not like
that yeah and it's just it's done
there's no practice no warm up it's done
so my mom was like bro i have to be an
athlete i just have to be and
um he did an iron man and basically long
story short skip to the end he isn't
like key athlete now
dope he lost those awake didn't iron man
challenge yeah yeah
um done a couple mother iron mans did
some other stuff a couple marathons
and then um i think he the way patton
did is he wanted to be a nike athlete so
obviously
he shouted nike they were like obviously
know
at the beginning oh well when he's i
think after he'd done a couple of iron
mans or something she shouted nike
basically i want to be a sponsored nike
athlete and they were like nah
um and he was like cool so he
on youtube made his own nike commercial
okay just made it up okay just made it
up okay and then he did it
apparently it went viral got millions of
views and then nike called him
and just said well go on okay and now
he's an ikea
okay so do you know what's crazy about
that because obviously you said
his first gig when he changed to ceo
charlie
he was a cameraman videographer
and obviously so he learned that skill
of how to exactly do videos
blah blah blah and now he decided [ __ ] i
don't want to be
a uh a cameraman but he's still got he
still got that talent there to [ __ ]
benefited him in the best way that's
crazy that's full cycle
that's crazy it's full cycle it's
[ __ ] sick
that's crazy i mean i said to you before
it was crazy that i was thinking about
how this like this one life to live
thing i was thinking about that probably
three or four days ago i was in a shower
and i was thinking we actually don't
know what happens
after we die oh of course like obviously
like there's this help there's heaven
there's
hell like oh some people that don't
believe in heroin don't believe in hell
some people might believe in
incarnation reincarnation some people
might not believe there's an afterlife
but it's like
we have no idea and i was thinking
imagine
there are supreme not supreme beings but
like
do wait first of all do you believe that
we are the only form of life in the
universe
of course not okay i don't believe that
either but i've got no evidence to back
that up do you know what i mean it's
just something i believe
i just can't fathom that we are the only
thing in the universe
i can't fathom that so
my brain went into like a spiral and i
was thinking
imagine let's call them supreme beings
for example there are supreme
beings watching us do our day-to-day
[ __ ] do you know what i mean like
like the way we watch love island big
brother all them things they're watching
us
live i think about that sometimes swear
down that's stoner chat
i love i love it when i when i get when
i get baked i think about
the most eccentric stuff because i can
never think about that when i'm sober
do you know what i mean i've got bills
to pay
is it true exactly exactly i've got [ __ ]
to do yeah i've got [ __ ] to do yeah yeah
but
stuff like that like i was just in my
zone i was just in my element and i just
thought
there's no way we're the only things on
this world in this universe it can't be
of course and there's there are times
where
i think i've said this to you before but
i say it's a bella all the time
um like when we sit down and chat like
when we we spoke the other day we
we got baked and we just chatted
whatever i was like ah i [ __ ] wish
this was recorded i always say to myself
i wish that memory was recorded and i
just feel like there's someone out there
in the universe
that's watching us do this and they're
the only ones that are seeing it
apart from me and whoever's in the room
do you know what i mean do you know
what's even more bonkers
than that that you can take at another
level but this is
not stupid but it's just like too much
it's too much in that if there was so
let's just not even
not even necessarily supreme beings
let's just say it was like another life
form
yeah but they were looking at us yeah if
they were
like from a different uh like galaxy or
anything like that obviously they're
light years away
yeah and obviously light years is based
on time
yeah so in order for them to see us
obviously that's the the the
the speed of light obviously so a light
year is
um obviously based on speed of light et
cetera et cetera
but so um
a light year is obviously the speed of
light over the period of a year right
so um if you're obviously
that makes sense but if it doesn't make
sense to you if you're a light year away
if you're going at the speed of light it
would take me a year to get to you
um if you're 100 light years away
you can watch it so they could be
watching us if they're 100 light years
away from us
they could be watching us our day to day
today and everything and just as you
said
no one's seeing it but you the the
people in the room
and these other beings that are watching
our day today today
but if they're 100 light years away
you're actually dead
you're actually dead you're not what
they're seeing
you're dead but they're seeing it as a
day to day
because of just the distance how far
they are but they're seen as normal just
how we see the stars
just how we when we hear when we see
lightning but hear it later
yeah exactly exactly like that yeah
exactly like that and when we look at
the stars
like a lot of stars are not even there
yeah but they're so far away
from our way we think they're still
there but that's just the time travel
that it takes to get
for the light to get to our eyes like
that is another level
that's another level that's [ __ ]
isn't it that's [ __ ] that's stoner
that's stoner chat
but yeah that's that's top stone in chat
that's that's that's crazy
stuff it is but um yeah stuff that
fascinates me sometimes
um but yeah man the ceo charlie's thing
oh and by the way
when he decided to be an athlete he
changed his name from ceo charlie to
charlie rocket
okay and that's why it's called charlie
rocket now okay but um
it just it made it to the point that i
already said
fascinates me that you can be in such a
privileged position
and still decide to suck it all off and
start again and not even just starting
again
starting to get into something where you
have a very slim chance of being
successful yeah yeah yeah
very slim chance it's not even at this
point to be a nike athlete
it's not about oh just consistence
and like um being consistent and um just
working hard every day and stuff like
that
and it all happened like no no no no no
probably still probably won't you can
work every day for the next 20 years it
still probably won't happen
but he just did it anyway and i was like
it's so easy
it's so easy to to to chase your dreams
when you've got [ __ ] all else going on
so easy of course and like
i sometimes that i think that made me
realize that i'm not doing it
not that i'm not doing enough but i feel
like
changed your dream or no i am doing
enough obviously this is my dream so i'm
definitely
i'm doing enough to chase my own dream
but when i'm sitting here preaching
about people chasing their their dreams
i think sometimes
that's a part of the the process that
i'm missing because i'm only reflecting
on people in my position
yes because i hate the position i'm in
yes i hate the
nine to five yes i hate the rat race i
hate all that [ __ ] yes
so me chasing my dream allows me to [ __ ]
off
that other thing yeah yeah to do what i
want to do yeah yeah
yeah and i don't make millions at the
job that i do now makes sense i'm going
to make millions doing this
so it's easy for me to hate it i want to
[ __ ] it off but if you are making
millions would you be doing the podcast
that's the question i think i would
we've had the discussion before
i'm 99 certain i would but the thing is
also as well was like
is yeah like how can i put it
when this like when i get to quit my job
in order for me to quit my job to do
this full-time mm-hmm
i don't have to make that much money
mm-hmm i have to make a bit
yeah make enough to i have to make
enough but the change over
is not loads so it's to me such a minor
yeah but if yeah again if i was making
millions
in order for me to quit my job to chase
my dream you'd have to give all that up
i have to give up because there's no way
that's going to happen yeah there's no
it would take forever to make as much as
i'm making
in order to just change it over yeah and
you'll just make it make it's so far
ahead you don't want to suck it off all
together yeah
and it's just like when he told me
obviously he didn't tell me but when he
was talking about that on the pod i was
like
[ __ ] bro you got some balls because i'm
sitting here i was thinking who the [ __ ]
am i i'm sitting here preaching
i'm sitting there preaching like people
need to chase the [ __ ] dreams [ __ ]
this [ __ ] that [ __ ] this [ __ ] that but
it's easy for me to say that yeah
it's easy for me to say that because i
hate the position i'm in
but if i loved the position i was in but
would i be still be so dedicated to
chasing my dream
that is the question and i still don't
know if i can answer it if i actually
was in a position that i
loved would i still want to chase my
dream but did he love managing
or did he just do it because it was did
he learn to love it because of the money
factor i think he learned to love it
because he said
he loved being a servant
to people okay he loved being able to
help
other excuse me bless you
um he he loved being able to
serve people in order to help them chase
their dream okay and he loved the fact
that he could be a completely
unbiased person and they could trust
that he's
in it for them yeah yeah yeah he's in it
for them because a lot of the stuff he
does now
is helping people so now that he's an
athlete and stuff like that he has he
runs initiatives to help people so like
um he'll like give people
shoes if they want to kind of like kevin
hart where he does okay like
shoe giveaways and there's a woman who
had like a a bad story about she lost
her legs
for the prosthesis and so he gave her a
prosthesis like he likes helping people
okay so i think
in that respect the management aspect
that's what he loved about it
okay he loved that but the helping
people okay and serving people and
bringing joy to other people that's what
he loved but again
that's not what his story was about like
that's not what he
grew up wanting to do um
so yeah i was just i was just taken
aback by a boy when when i
listened to i was like [ __ ] [ __ ] i've
been
not saying the wrong thing the whole
time i've been saying the right thing
but
only a small
because i'm sure a large percent of the
people are not making millions
but the small percentage of people that
could have been listening to me say
do this do that do this do that that are
comfortable that are comfortable yeah
it could be like [ __ ] you have no idea
do you know what i mean yeah you think
you know [ __ ] you have no idea what it
would take for me to chase my dreams
you have no idea and like it just
happens to be that coincidentally
and the thing is well i think it was
cool because his
the dream that he had his money couldn't
help him
that's what resonated with me as well
okay okay okay because for example if i
want to do the podcast as a dream
and i was making millions over here i
could just invest loads of money to make
sure
that i get up there quickly yeah no i
mean we could buy the best
studio we could buy producers we can buy
whatever we need to make
give us an upper step yes so we won't
have to start from the ground yeah so we
want to lose 50 of them we have
connections we would have we could buy
advertising space we could
invest enough money to get us up there
enough
so the transfer yes we'd have to take a
massive pay cut but it wouldn't be as
bad yeah makes sense whereas the the
dream that he had
was so far removed from what his actual
life was
that all the money he made over here
couldn't help him it really couldn't
help it did nothing for him
and he still chased his dream anyway and
that's a different thing as well
that's a different thing as well so like
yeah stuff like that i was just like
[ __ ] he shits on me he shits on me
all day every day i like that
it was dope i like that i enjoyed it i
enjoyed it it was cool man i love
something i love inspirational [ __ ] like
that yeah yeah
and i think a lot of it as well he went
off on that in terms of
the manifestation aspect of things as
well which is like the second part of it
okay but the second part of it was all
about how he manifested his dreams yeah
and i said to you the other day i'm big
on this manifestation thing at the
minute
because it just how do i explain it
so me and for context me if you have a
goals list
um i've got a manifestation thing you're
specifically talking about
yeah yeah um me if we have a goals list
and we tick off the goals it's all the
time
yeah and i'm certain
that we will take off all of it oh we
will but i don't
know yeah i know i know i know i know i
know you know i mean i don't know that
no one knows anything no one knows that
when you first sent me the list
some of the [ __ ] on those thinking this
is gonna take forever
this is gonna take forever but all it
takes is one thing
all it takes is one video one tweet one
this one that and before you know it you
can make it
from when i send you the list we had
like two ticks we had two ticks now
we've got like 12
we've got so and you said to me by the
end
by the end of this list you want to make
another list but you know for a fact by
the end of this list we would have made
it
so the second list is just greed now do
you know what i mean
do you know what i mean the second list
is calm
we've quit our jobs by the end of the
first list yes yes yes and that's
crazy to me but i do unders i understand
the manifestation
i'm pretty sure it's like two things
done it must be it must be we've done
loads on it we've done loads on that
list already and it makes no sense how
it's come so quick
because it's not like you made this list
when we started this podcast
oh i know you made this list we were in
we were in it's probably about two
months maybe
yeah maybe you made this list and we've
ticked off so
many it's unbelievable yeah yeah so we
were about just over half i just counted
we're about
just over halfway there i think and the
second last yeah yeah the second half is
like
filth you know i mean yeah yeah yeah
yeah the second half is it's hard to get
but
it's not as hard as it looks considering
the kind of trajectory
trajectory we're having do you know what
i mean
it's easier to get to those points than
it was to get to some of the first
points
yeah do you know what i mean yeah yeah
that's another thing he was talking
about was um so
one was obviously chasing your dreams
yeah two was manifest
manifesting things yeah so in terms of
the manifesting um
the reason i bought the list is because
you don't know what you're gonna get
yeah you don't know anything's gonna
happen
yeah but if you when i the way my mind
works is i get so certain of things yeah
and then the way i was talking to lewis
about it
and it turns into what
you're you that you might not think that
you've been manifesting things but when
you actually
take a second and look back you think
[ __ ]
i've been manifesting things forever so
i've always said
i've said it on here i've said to you
the way my brain has always worked
and you would know this from knowing me
and stuff like that and everyone knows
who knows me
i'm big on like accountability so if i
want to do something
i tell there's many people in the world
that i want to do it yeah yeah so you
have one so it puts me in the corner and
i have to do it yeah yeah
so anytime i've ever wanted to do
something big even from getting tattoos
to getting my driver's license to to
going on a holiday to
starting this to do anything i've always
said
i'm telling as many people as i can not
to show off or anything like that but
just because if i tell more people
i'm less likely to back out if i keep it
to myself
i can't yeah
um so i go and tell everyone everyone
and i make sure that i get it done i
make sure it happens even if it's out my
control yeah
and make sure it [ __ ] happens and it
always does
it always does and like um some of the
things you think oh that's luck
and some of the things you think like oh
i did it because i said i was gonna do
it yeah yeah
um because a lot of times it's happened
with like jobs and stuff like that and
like it's happened like with this and
stuff
and everything like every time we take
off something on the list i'm always
like i told you i told you i told you
yeah and it is
[Laughter]
yeah i was like i [ __ ] told you but
yes i told you but i didn't [ __ ] know
yeah yeah but when but then deep down
you think
maybe i did know because maybe i
manifested this or we manifested this
like maybe
it this is manifestation maybe it's not
just luck yeah or maybe it's not just
how things go maybe that's not just
because people people like to think
there's a blueprint to [ __ ] yeah you
know what i'm saying yeah
like a b equals c people i'd say if you
do this and you do this you would do
this that's why people have [ __ ]
um stock market [ __ ] tutoring
sessions
and seminars and all that [ __ ] yeah let
me show you the secret how to do this
people like to think that there's an
algorithm for everything
and it's just not the tr it's just not
the case like we could not
this is like mother nature is a [ __ ] so
we could never get another follower or
another subscriber ever again
and that is a fact it's unlikely but
it's a fact we could just everything
could stop here and we could lose
everything
like it could all go and that's just how
it is but
when he was talking about the
manifestation thing i was like bro that
is
resonating with me so hard because you
think back at [ __ ]
and you like bro maybe that was
manifestation maybe it wasn't just luck
because some things i'm so certain are
going to happen but i have no way of
knowing that they're going to happen
when how where where
all that is going to happen i mean it
just happens yeah i had no way of
knowing that was ever going to happen
like
just starting this thing all together
all the things that have happened
first so far i said all of them would
happen but i had no idea
i've never done it before i don't
[ __ ] know i don't even know anyone
who has
yeah so i didn't even have a reference
pointer very true very true yeah i have
no idea
but i was so certain that it would and
it has um so when you're talking about
that stuff i was like i
understand where you're coming from so
the first one was chasing your dreams
second one was manifesting the things
that you want in your life yeah and he
said about writing it down which is why
actually why i brought up the gossip in
the first place he said when you write
things down and actually statistically
speaking
it's something there's actually a crazy
statistic that says like
your goals that you write down are
literally like 40
more likely to happen than goals that
you just keep in your head yeah and that
doesn't make sense
but it's a fact um so yeah second one
was manifestation the third one was
momentum
okay and that goes to the list as well
because
momentum is literally the most powerful
thing
ever and you can take kind of examples
of momentum wherever you find it yeah so
just like you said about when he was a
cameraman before and he didn't want to
be a cameraman anymore yeah but he's got
those skills and he when he moved into
what he wanted to do
it is catapult it is literally the
reason
he got what he wanted yeah because he
did that [ __ ] thing ages ago
that he didn't necessarily worry about
skills transferable skills and talking
about like momentum how i said about
there's things there's things on that
list
that seem so far-fetched yeah
but we're in when it actually happens
will probably happen easier than some of
the early things
day one stuff day one stuff that was on
the list was so
hard to get so hard to get because we
didn't have the momentum there was no
momentum
exactly what i'm trying to say there's
there was no momentum
whatsoever it was starting from [ __ ]
nothing scratch
scratch nothing to keep you going but
once you are going
it just goes it just goes no i'm getting
shivers
yeah i'm getting shivers there was no
momentum
there was nothing [ __ ] there was nothing
but once you have momentum you can just
go
and you can do whatever you want as long
as you have the momentum
you just have to get the ball going just
and keep [ __ ] going
exactly and another thing that he said
on there i'm just basically
just i'm just stealing the whole podcast
yeah yeah
and regurgitating it onto my own podcast
so that people listen and be like
[Laughter]
[ __ ] it but yeah so another thing he
said about the momentum
is that he transferred that and to way
he sees things so if he wants to start
something
exactly we said about this on a podcast
another uh ages ago
in terms of he says everything is easy
he said it's done
okay he said anything he wants to do
he's like calm it's done okay
it's done it's done like if the stuff on
the list when we've got some of the
the big things on there that seems so
far-fetched and unattainable
he would think about it and say he's
done okay it's already done okay
because i've got the momentum to keep me
going and the reason he said the reason
i think about
starting something and if i ever want to
start something the reason i say it's
easy
is because people enjoy doing [ __ ]
that's easy yeah people love doing [ __ ]
that's easy
so if you can think in your head bruv
this is easy yeah i can do it
you're more likely to start and once you
start
you'll have momentum yeah and like he tr
um he another guy that was on there
related to it to when he got into
like uh mountain biking and he wanted to
do like bike races and stuff
and he said the momentum that got him
because he was fat and overweight he had
really bad eating issues as well this is
completely there's a different guy that
was on the pod as well he used to be 300
as well coincidentally and he said
cycling's what did it for him okay and
he said the momentum of the cycling
which is just like a weird coincidence
but the momentum of cycling that got him
there was
is that he had it like obviously bad
eating habits and didn't exercise was
like all right cool let me just start
getting on the bike
so just the fact that he's getting on
the bike and then we do easy [ __ ] on the
bike
and he was like oh i like going fast on
the bike i get gas when i go faster
so let me get to the hills to go fast
but in order to go down the hills i have
to go up the hill
yeah so let me just get there because
i'm having fun and he's like fast fast
fast fast fast
sick sick sick sick sick well if i want
to go fast i need to get bigger hills
so i need to be able to get up the hills
and i've realized if i eat less
i can get up the hills better so he
wasn't even thinking about changing his
diet habits he just wanted to go faster
yeah on the bike that's all he cared
about
and the momentum it just kept going and
going and now i don't need to eat this
and now i hear this or maybe if i buy
this and get this and this and this
also he can go faster and all of a
sudden he's lost like 150 pounds
wow and the reason he got on the bike
was to lose the weight but the process
of going through it
had nothing to do with losing weight
yeah just enjoying what you were doing
every day found it easier more fun more
fun how can we make this more fun more
fun more fun more fun more fun and then
it just took care of it the momentum
took care of the rest
what he had to do was focus on the fun
part which you just you need one tap you
need one push and then literally
momentum
and it works with everything that you've
ever done yeah you never have to push it
again
just one now and you just go you'd never
have to push that's why i pissed you off
that ting and go ape
that's what fished you off you just
needed the tap you just needed the
momentum to take you
i don't know if i've spoken about this
one here you might have i can't remember
context we went to go away in i think it
was milton keynes or site i remember
where it was
like like bedfordshire somewhere in
arsenal it was us
it was the lads uh this was five sec
seven years ago i don't know go with and
i think it was on the
like one of the last um activities to do
we had to jump
off some high hiding and like swing down
to a net
oh i think i was the first one to go i
don't remember i don't remember
you were before me i know that 100 was
before this card i was on the edge of it
i was thinking i can't jump like i'm
shook i'm shook but i was psyching
myself up to do it
yeah this [ __ ] pushed me off i
have never screamed
so loud in my life i thought i was gonna
die how do i know
i thought i was gonna die oh i know i
hated you that day i know you did
i'm sorry g you're not you're not i
hated you that i am and i'm not
i'm not now obviously not but
i could never understand how scared you
were actually work you will never
understand
you wouldn't it's like you said
obviously you said you wanted to go
skydiving for your 30th correct
imagine me pushing you off but i need it
that's the thing i don't think i would
bother me because i'd need it because
i'm going to be terrified i
want someone to push me off because i
need to be pushed off
because otherwise i won't go oh no you
have to go and after everyone yeah it's
true oh yeah so yes skydiving
accountability yeah
yeah manifested counter billy i'm 30th
birthday
so that's not until next april so we've
got a while i'm gonna go skydiving and
jump out a [ __ ] plane
we've spoken about this like when we're
talking about australia and animals and
[ __ ] saying we
we don't i don't like putting myself in
danger and [ __ ] like that so now i have
to skydive it's true because i didn't
want to bungee jump i don't want to go
in the [ __ ] ocean i don't want to i
don't want none of that [ __ ] because i
want to live
it's true it's true it's true i want to
live but now so cool
am i the [ __ ] am i the [ __ ] all
right gang
that was a great episode that was cool
man i really enjoyed it uh
right am i the [ __ ] for no longer
inviting my sister anywhere because
she's turned to a stereotypical vegan
love it ah i'm gonna love this one right
cool
so long let me try and i haven't it's
annoying because i haven't read it
so i can't do the notes right cool so
situation is caused a lot of drama in my
family blah blah blah but i feel like
i'm completely right
uh of course for fifth and running
siblings
all right cool me and my siblings always
been thick as thieves
uh i think that means they're close
right i think it's these
i think that means they're tight despite
the age differences yeah yeah we moved
into the city
so this is a time vegan and now of
course
i don't know sister's turn vegan i
didn't give a damn about eating habits
um and i'm fine with specifically
checking restaurants who have vegan
options
but she went religiously vegan within
the space of a few weeks
um it started with annoying near
constant comments concerning
me and my siblings eating habits typical
vegan [ __ ]
um that turned into passive aggressive
snyder remarks about i in a few months
went on um
full on bitterly
prose prosel
there's a word in there i don't
understand let me see p r
i need to see it don't spell it fine all
right because we're going to process it
cool cool cool
it's under however so third line down
first word in the third line down
prospect
preselta zing i don't know what that
means cross-saltising proselytizing i
don't know
after google yeah google docs
embarrassing people gonna think we're
illiterate yeah but i've never seen that
word of mine
i've never seen that word in my life my
entire life pro continue anyway pro
yeah anyway uh a few months she went
full-on
bitterly proselytizing her lifestyle to
everybody
p-r-o-s yeah e-l-t-y z-i-n-g
all right it's when it comes it's not
even a word it's a word oh what does it
mean
converts it makes sense now convert or
attempt to convert someone from one
religion belief or opinion to another
okay
it makes so much sense yeah okay cool
cool cool cool i've never seen that word
in my entire life
so yeah in 2019 converting her lifestyle
to everyone yeah just use
plain english because [ __ ] now you've
complained about [ __ ] veganism you
can't use [ __ ] english
anyway right cool um okay cool so yeah
converting everyone their lifestyle uh
she turned everything towards veganism
so okay
should say how's your leg injury fine i
think my lifestyle really sped up the
healing process
see that right there
that right there i will fight you
no one no one could ever tell me whether
it's veganism
ketogenic diet yeah carnivore diet
[ __ ] atkins diet no one could ever
tell me that their eating habits are the
reason their
their leg feels so much better so much i
will fight you on the spot
[ __ ] off [ __ ] off um
cool cool cool um so i told her to
turn it down dozens of times but she
won't listen it was at that point i just
stopped speaking to her
um as much as i used to and i made the
choice not to invite her to my house or
if i had to any restaurants
um without me influencing anyone my
brother started to do the same thing
and so i did a lot of our extended uh
family so decided to slowly like cut her
out
cue her panicking and being full of
tears and my parents constantly calling
us and asking what she did
while of course ignoring it when we told
her now she's accusing us of alienating
her
ganging up in there bullying her and so
forth and my parents have since begged
me
to just forgive and forget and deal with
it because she's driving them insane
so it's either arsenal for locking her
off um
that's a tough one actually it's a tough
one considering they were tires
or whatever thicker sleeves or whatever
an energy they used prior
yeah um okay it's
yes and no because everyone is entitled
to their lifestyle choice
like if you decided to be vegan
one day and that was your choice i'm not
going to stop being your best friend
of course you know what i mean of course
that's your choice and you want to do
that
fine by me um
and i feel like personally i would find
it easier to adjust to it anyway because
i work in hospitality
yeah anyway so i understand what people
have to go through when they go to
restaurants to try and
patent a vegan meal anyway so for me it
will be easier
for people like my man that might not
even be in that field or whatever that
don't even understand the concepts
i understand why it's hard harder for
them to
adapt or to adapt to the change of
someone else rather
accommodate them that's the way i'm
looking for to accommodate them that's
what i was looking for
it's he's not an [ __ ] for
um alienating her because she
has made not necessarily made it her
life goal to make sure
that everyone knows she's a vegan but
she's
she's not also just trying to change her
life she's trying to change people
around her
which is then affecting let's say you're
trying to change my life you're then
affecting my free will
have no right in telling me what to eat
and what not to eat same way i have no
right to tell you so if you want to be a
vegan
by all means do what you want because
it's not affecting me
that's the thing well i think that's a
that's a good important point is that
is that people like to get on about
other people not accommodating
not accommodating veganism let's just
use i'm talking about any kind of
dietary requirements yeah
but you also have to accommodate
everyone else yeah so people think
i think a lot of the time people think
because they're in the minority that
everyone should accommodate them
and they shouldn't have to accommodate
anyone else you know what i mean um
and like that's another thing as well i
was like if you're
if you want to go vegan calm don't give
a [ __ ] if you want to preach veganism
annoying those are two different things
yeah annoying
i might say stop the locking her off
part
is a bit much way too much it's way too
much now like if they're as tight as
because i can understand
situations so if i if if i have an
acquaintance
we're kind of friends and we're in a mix
and then i'm having to deal with that
obviously i'm not close enough with them
to be like big man shut your [ __ ]
mouth
and stop preaching this veganism thing
anymore if i said that to you
we could still be fine yeah because
we're tight yeah we're tight i can say
what i want to you and you know where my
heart is
if i don't know you that well and i'm
sick of you preaching i might have to
lock you off
he said they're siblings for one and
they're thick as thieves
so obviously he's saying oh she doesn't
want to listen to
what we're suggesting when we're saying
we're annoying stuff like that but
you should be tight enough that she
should be
she should have no confusion as to why
she's been locked off yeah
which means which makes me feel like you
are the [ __ ] for looking off because
you can't
i've told her yeah the way she needs to
be told yeah before you locked her off
yeah
like so he wasn't brutally honest you
need to be brutally honest
yeah if you're tight enough you need to
be like big man you were annoying the
[ __ ] out of me with this [ __ ]
and you're pissing me off and you're
making me not want to invite you places
because of how annoying you are with
your veganism
like you should be able to say that to
your sibling without
no qualms with no qualms no qualms and
not even think about repercussions i
love you i want to keep inviting you to
my house
i want to keep going to restaurants with
you but shut up the way you're acting
makes me not want to do it
yeah so you need to [ __ ] stop yeah
and then they should be able to like all
right calm
i want to eat how i'm going to eat you
want to eat how you want to eat i'm calm
to go to vegan restaurants i'm calm to
cook you vegan can't that just be enough
and if and then obviously then when she
gets locked off if she doesn't want to
stop then that's her own business yeah
but yeah um it's just about the way you
say it yeah clearly he didn't do that
he or she anyway clearly they didn't do
that
because if they did then she wouldn't be
running to their parents like what the
[ __ ] why is everyone knocking me off
exactly so i think you are a bit of an
[ __ ] for locking off because that's
your sister yeah you can't just
you can't lock her off based on that if
you're not gonna give her the harsh
truth
if you're not gonna give her the option
the true option to change because people
can take
little tidbits and they're like oh
haters haters haters haters they're not
ready
for the vegan um but yeah if you put it
on a plate
like this is it yeah and then they don't
want to make the change then that's
different but clearly
from the sounds of it you definitely
didn't do that yeah definitely didn't do
that um when you were talking about like
the preaching stuff and the um
uh what's what's it the minority being
like the minority if you're the minority
you want everyone to listen to you but
if you are the majority blah blah blah
so i know someone i'm not gonna say the
name during the
the george floyd incident um
she was actively promoting
like on you know how everyone was
promoting like the black lives matter
making more awareness and blah blah yeah
and she said to me that how she
kept on trying to influence her friends
to do the same
which from her perspective i understand
was a great
thing and what she intended to do was
great
but she's not i flipped it on her
because
she's not a
she doesn't necessarily not believe in
god but she doesn't
practice christianity or anything and i
said to her imagine if one of your
friends was preaching christianity to
you every single day down your throat
how
as soon as i said that she was like i
[ __ ] i [ __ ] gay
because you can't you can't force people
to see what you see
of course you just have to tell them and
let them do without as they will you
have to give them the opportunity to see
the opportunity to see you if you force
something down someone's throat then
immediately you're going to get
immediate it's a reflex they're
immediately going to gag
unless you've done a little bit yeah
obviously yeah
but she knows who she is yeah yeah yeah
do you know what i mean so it's
as soon as you say i wouldn't know who
it is because i had the exact same
conversation it resonated with me
yeah so you can't force things upon
people you just have to let people live
their lives that's why i said to you
to you if you were the vegan i would let
you do what you like it doesn't bother
me that you're a vegan
as long as you're not letting it trying
to impact my life
because i am my own person you can't
affect my free will it's unfortunate
i can't i don't force people to do [ __ ]
yeah just like i said to you earlier
i've never once asked someone to listen
to this
oh watch it i've never once asked one
person to do it because
i don't want to force people to do
something they don't want to do it yeah
yeah i don't want to put people in an
awkward position
of stuff like that i would never ask
that of someone so if you want i give
them the opportunity
the links are there the links are there
we do the little the clips are in my
story yeah
yeah i don't dm to people i don't jump
in your in your messages like watch it
watch it watch it like i don't do that
like the opportunity is there if you
want to you can if you don't want to
you it's fine yeah and like yeah i hate
being forced into [ __ ]
i hate being pressured to do [ __ ]
especially stuff that's nothing to do
with me
like you've gone on your own vegan
journey that's fine i wasn't there along
with you
so you can't just force it on me like
i'm just an innocent bystander here i'm
just trying to hang out with my sister
cuz like why are you doing this to me
yes exactly what you said about the the
the black marshmallow thing that is a
big deal
to me that's a big deal because you're
right you can't force people to see what
you see
you have to give them the opportunity to
see and if they don't want to then they
don't want to
and that's fine and that christian thing
is actually a big that is a good one
that's a great analogy
it's a great analogy and it doesn't
surprise me the fact that before you
even finish your sentence
she was like not even that hard she was
like yeah i get i get it i get it i get
it i get it because
everyone hates bible bashing [ __ ]
everyone hates again like jehovah's
witnesses that come to your [ __ ]
house uninvited
no one enjoys that and it sucks because
i will never be a child's witness now
just because that they do that they
force it on you and
now i will never do it um because they
make me gag
cool but yeah anyway wrap it your app
rapid rap see you next week guys